sorry that I came back no how about this
for a flush back Friday
that was the beginning Wow
then there's the test we gotta watch the
kiss or maybe that's awkward I don't
know either way it's good awkward is it
good or poor so Susan and I go way back
and both of us remember when I was a
soap newbie they're like okay so for
your second day you're gonna go work
with Susan Lucci like a television icon
and you're gonna get naked stand there
in your other work and they called you
snaps say cuz usually what are your
clothes off and in order to get him off
quickly they put your buttons on snap
chief like the legendary Erica Kane for
41 years
she is a daytime TV legend what do you
miss most about Erica Kane she was such
a juicy character I mean it was so much
fun to be high playing her in airports
and things people stop and say how much
they they really loved the show and and
to hear all that now because you know
there was a period of mourning but the
people still feel so affected by by it
and it keeps me company in that respect
you know here but Lucci fans rejoice she
is back as diva like Beverly Hills
housewife for season four of devious
maids which required this Peter darling
how do you two know each other
saw the trailer for season four there's
a little singing there's a quick little
shot of their hide on the couch are so
very strategically placed perhaps in the
right places how do you kind of get to a
place where you feel comfortable being
more exposed like that I don't think I
found that long no no it's always just
like you know a lot of butterflies and a
preparation you hope you did everything
you're supposed to do lots of extra
Pilates and not eating lunch and you
know all of that stuff